hello everyone and welcome to another
very enjoyable game we'll be showing
from round two of the us chess
championship many of you have requested
it and as always uh for good reasons
it's a daniel naradiski versus jeffrey
xiong uh and it's uh as you might have
expected a very very complicated game
but that's why we're why we're here uh
so let's uh check it out and hopefully
enjoy it uh so uh naritsky with the
white pieces opens with d4 we have
knight to f6 knight to f3 d5 and now e3
going for the coal system uh so waiting
with the advancement of the c4 pawn uh
we have c5 by black challenging white
center and knight b to d2 now we have e6
now preparing to develop the dark square
bishop castle to safety and now b3 by
white c3 is what's usually played here
b3
a little less common but still played we
have b6 by black and bishop to b2 now i
think in catering the dark square bishop
with bishop to d6 just continuing
development preparing the castle and now
there are a few games where bishop b5
check was played but here we have bishop
to d3 and it is now already as of move
seven that we have a completely new game
black decides to capture on d4 uh this
is probably some uh prepared idea as uh
it doesn't seem to bring you anything
and capturing just for the sake of
captures is never good as we've seen
many times
but uh here as it's so early in the in
in the opening of it definitely
is something that that's prepared so c
characters on the e4 we have e captures
on d4 and now bishop to a6 trying to
trade off white's powerful light square
bishop as our own bishop on c8 isn't
really doing all that much so c4 of
course naruditsuki wants to prevent this
and now both players just castle
castle's castles and knight b to d7
so here we have knight to e5 and here
if you've ever played uh against the
queen's pawn opening with black and
maybe you've only just started playing
chess and white plays knights to e5 this
is the most annoying move uh in chess in
general like when that knight the e5
lands uh it will uh just harass you for
the rest of the game and it's very
frustrating when you're starting to play
chess so it's best just to relax and uh
will accept the simple truth that this
knight is not going anywhere anytime
soon so many have tried moving this
knight and dislodging it with f6 trading
bishop for night of course doesn't
really do all that much because we just
uh well give up the bishop pair for no
reason and we can very easily
get checkmated so you have to be very
careful with ideas like this g6 queen h6
now the knight can come to g5
and you're getting checkmated very
easily so this is something that could
happen and of course we can't capture
with the knight because then we're going
to lose a piece so this knight when it
lands on e5 in positions like these it
stays there so you don't don't stress
about that if it happens in your own
game so rook to c8 just continuing the
game uh and f4 now uh really solidifying
that knight on f4 on e5 but also
preparing f5 we want to open up the f
file for our rook
so bishop back to b7 and now comes queen
to e2 the rooks are now connected the
other rook can come into the game we
have rook to c7 the idea is to bring to
bring the queen to a8 and then the queen
bishop battery will be very impressive
on this diagonal for example after it
opens up
rook 8 to e1 now the rooks are nicely
placed and queen to a8 black has to
figure out a way on how to activate
pieces and now as the black queen left
all the way to the queen side
naruditsuki decides to open up with f5
uh so what do you play here uh we have e
captures bishop capture sorry not bishop
capture so rook captures and now we have
rook to e8 so placing the rook on the
same file as the queen definitely makes
sense and now rook e to f1 doubling up
on the f-file there's a lot of pressure
on that f7 pawn if this knight moves
it's going to fall also rook to g5 will
be a very strong attacking maneuver so
rook to e6
this will be a very helpful defending
piece and also you can just shift it
easily into the attack if needed so c
captures on d5 we have bishop captures
on d5 and now knight d to c4 putting
pressure on black's dark square bishop
here we finally have knight captures on
e5 and now not knight captures but d
captures on e5 attacking the knight and
the bishop here
so what can you play the problem is if
you play something like bishop captures
and c4 and bishop captures on c4 uh what
do you do here your knight is hanging
your rook is hanging you have to play
something like bishop the c5 check king
h1 but there's no good move you can make
uh if you move the knight you
you're going to lose the rook also f7
becomes weak so this would be completely
winning for white
uh so instead after the captures on e5
we have bishop the c5 with check now
look at uh xiung's bishops they're so
impressively placed that it's hard to
imagine that you can
survive this look at this rook ready to
jump to h6 it's going to be very very
difficult defending this so king the h1
knights the e for now and this knight is
now a monster uh the problem is you can
never capture on f7 or something like
this okay for the moment the
rook is guarding this but even if it
wasn't uh if you just move at night the
g3 check wins the game uh the problem is
uh knight to g3 checkpoint captures rook
to h6 and it's game over there's not
much you can do about this so here we
have rook five to f4 this is a trick not
trying to
get black to sacrifice the knight but
now sacrificing the knight wouldn't
really work because after each captures
on g3 our pawn is guarding the h4 square
hence rooked for move and now if rook to
h6 we can simply block with rook to h4
we're up a piece and we are now winning
it still looks very ugly because the
bishop pair is just beautiful here
but we shouldn't have any problems
defending this so instead after rook
five to f4 uh xiong played f5 and this
f5 is such a such a great move that it's
uh hard to find a way around it uh the
thing is uh if you play something like e
captures on f6 alpha sound then knight
cap knight to g3 check is again winning
for black now h captures and g3 uh we
pick up the queen so this pawn was very
important on e5 we can never capture our
poisson
and if you play something like rook
captures on f5 then knight to g3 check
is again winning because after this
sacrifice we captured rook the h6 and
now yes i know you guys see that the
rook can block with rook to h5 but after
this we play bishop captures on g2 with
check and what do you play here there's
nothing you can do if you capture with
the queen then rook captures an h5 is
checkmate so you could move the king but
then bishop captures on f1 and there is
no way for white to hold on to
everything uh the queen can't really
move because you have to guard against
checkmate here if the queen moves from
the defense of the rook rook captures an
h5 is coming so black is completely
winning here so uh what did naruti find
here in this position after f5 well he
founded the move that's
more often than not the best move in any
given position and that of course is
pawn to b4 and this is a beautiful move
it comes with a there it says all right
capture my pawn
and there are many possibilities here
that you can consider but xiong decided
to boldly capture the pawn uh just uh
i'll show you how complicated the
position is you could play something
like b5 attack uh the knight on c4 you
could play something like g5 attack the
rook here for example g5 the rook is
attacked we could play bishop captures
an e for now threatening bishop captures
on d5 so bishop captures and now we even
play rook captures on e4 and the the
bishop here will still be hanging so
after queen captures we're gonna play
queen captures f captures you have to
pick up our queen b captures on c5 rook
captures and now let's say knight to e3
and we would have two pieces for a rook
so this is one option that um
you could play after this annoying b4
move
the other one of course is this b5 move
so what could you play here again we're
gonna capture on e4 and after bishop
captures now go after this bishop knight
to d2 uh now we're going to play bishop
captures on b4 and after knight captures
here f captures here we're gonna play
queen captures on b5 and it's uh equal
material but white should be a little
bit better the rooks are nicely doubled
here okay the bishop is
attacking its own e5 pawn but still it's
a pass pawn black also has a passport so
it would be an extremely double ditch
position uh so this is what was possible
here like g5b5 but uh
boldly accepted this he played bishop
captures on b4 much like you would uh
when uh facing the evans gambit and now
knight to e3 now this move is uh uh
completely different uh than when the
bishop was here on c5 as the bishop
cannot capture on e3 so what can you
play here well the f5 pawn is hanging so
we might as well defend this and we're
gonna have to give up our bishop pair uh
and this is the absolute best of course
for black so g6 is played guarding the
f5 pawn now a3 pushing the bishop back
we have bishop back to e7 and now knight
captures on d5 we have queen captures on
d5 and now queen to f3 not allowing the
knight to move as the queen would hang
and what can you play here well it's a
very difficult position and xiung in
fact plays the absolute strongest move
for black but that's exactly what uh
daniel wanted he plays knight to c3 now
the queens are uh
opposing each other and the knight here
guards the queen so what do you play uh
here bishop the c4 that's the good stuff
and you might
have noticed that the queen rook and
king are on the same diagonal so this is
a very powerful move now we can't really
just ignore this for example if we play
queen captures on f3 first white
captures an e6 with check only then we
recapture the queen and we're winning
we're up to much material so here after
bishop to c4 best is just to capture
this bishop so rook captures on c4 and
don't worry it's not a free piece
because we're going to remove the
defender of the rook so queen captures
on the five knight captures and now rook
captures on c4 and now white is up the
exchange however black is up a pawn so
how can how can you continue here uh
well b5 is played attacking the bishop
to c5 seems a bit safer as it prevents
the rook from activating along the c
file but okay b5 we have two to one
advantage on the queen side so we could
even try and create a pass pawn here uh
rook to c8 check king to f7 now comes
rook to f3 uh so what do you play here
uh we have knights to b6 chasing back
the rook rook the c7 now going after the
a7 pawn and now knight to c4 going after
the bishop here so the bishop has to
move bishop to c3 and now you have to
decide how how to continue here
it's not easy there are many options you
could capture on e5 you could capture an
a3 you could decide to save your a7 pawn
and play something like a6 so many
options for black all depends on what
kind of a player you are so knight
captures an e5 is played here
white must react to this as the rook
here on f3 is attacked so rook the h3
going after the pawn here and now h5 and
only now white captures on a7 so rook
captures on a7
and now f4
it's a very tricky move uh f3 is coming
at some point this will not only uh mess
up white's pawn structure but also
remove the rook's defense of the of the
bishop and c3 so could be very important
in some lines so rook to b7 going after
the b5 pawn now rook to c6 and now what
we've discussed if this pawn lands here
then you will no longer be defending
your bishop and if the bishop moves you
might even run into a backrank checkmate
so white has to be very careful here but
for the moment uh the tactics work in
white's favor so rook captures on b5 now
there's a double attack on the knight
here uh so
and of course we mentioned that you
can't just grab the knight you're going
to get checkmated so rook captures on b5
goes after the knight here
bishop to f6 defending and now rook to
b1 you have to take care of your back
rank issues
and now we have knight to g4 a very
tricky move and there is only one way
for whites to continue and keep enjoying
his advantage so feel free to pause the
video and try to find this very
interesting move while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on not playing
anything weird like uh well there's many
many things you could do here like
bishop captures uh on f6 uh that that
would be weird
but for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course bishop e1
we guard the f2 square and now we
prevent knight to f2 and now we can
simply put our rook behind the pass pawn
somehow and start pushing our pass pawn
uh the problem is if you play something
like rook captures bishop captures on f6
then this knight to f2 check is too
annoying you're going to capture the
rook again with checking captures on f6
equal material it's a king and rook and
pawn end game of course this is this is
a dead draw so after bishop to e1 now
it's problem for black so what can black
do we have rook to c2 now again going
after that c2 square but now rook to f3
you don't really care you're on a light
square uh so
the bishop can't really harass the rook
here and you're attacking the pawn so g5
defending this pawn and now h3 chasing
away the knight 95 attacks the rook and
now rook f2 not only offering a trade of
rooks but also after the rook moves
because of course you're not going to
trade here then a rook is coming to a2
and then we start pushing our past pawn
so rook to c4
and now comes rook to a2 so preparing to
push the the pass pawn and now if black
wants to have a very passive game black
would play rook to a4 and then try to
drag this out but uh she only decided to
play an active game and he played f3 uh
so what do you do here well white
ignores this a4 he starts pushing his
pass pawn now comes rook to e4 now
knight to d3 could pose some problems as
the bishop will be attacked twice also
knight will be able to come to f2 at
some point maybe you could push the pawn
to f2 so all depends on what white plays
but here we have bishop to g3 just a
very very solid move f captures on g2
with check king captures and now knight
to d3 so trying to create some problems
here but
white says there's nothing here we have
a5
for now chasing back the bishop but now
even a6 white says i need no bishop i
can simply promote my pawn to a queen
and that's it we have h captures on g3
it's the best black has now comes a7 and
now knight to f4 with check uh checking
if white might be scared to maybe grab
the pawn because if you play something
like king to g1 then bishop d4 check is
a problem for example king h1 g2 check
and if you don't want to lose the game
you're going to have to capture here uh
remove your defender of the pawn and now
bishop captures here and now it's a
dead raw we're going to play some like
rook b7 check king g6 uh we're going to
capture on a7 we're going to capture on
g2 king captures and now it's of course
a dead draw so after knight to it for
check uh nordic boldly grabbed the g3
pawn now comes rook to e3 check and now
even king to g4 and he was in this
position on move 52 that jeffrey xiong
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here you could capture
on h3 but then we bring a queen into the
game and even after this check we could
even play king to f5 and now you can see
that the king is on a light square
everything else is on a dark square
there's no way to
even continue harassing this white king
so there are no uh tricks left of course
uh after king to g4 uh the best move was
simply to resign the game so yeah uh
very nicely done a very nice victory by
uh by daniel naradicki i hope you guys
enjoyed it it was a very very
complicated game we showed many lines
but we could have shown many many more
as uh that this game was simply really
really complicated uh but that is often
the case when uh such such young players
face each other over the board uh of
course uh they will complicate and uh
that's simply where they where they
thrive and where their their strengths
are
uh so yeah and once again hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank nima
uh
michael kennedy tom darrell and robert
kiefer for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing the
coverage of the us chess championship uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank y'all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day